for example
foreign
foreign
the Russian Federation has repeatedly
spread disinformation
including wild claims involving dirty
bombs
chemical weapons
how much more of this nonsense do we
have to endure
colleagues I am going to keep my remarks
short because frankly this meeting is a
waste of everyone's time
Russia has called us here once again for
the sole purpose of spreading
disinformation
we all know these claims are pure
Fabrications brought forth without a
shred of evidence
and I would even venture to say the
Russian delegation knows these charges
are fabricated but they dutifully carry
out marching orders from President Putin
all Russia has a bizarre conspiracies
conspiracies that are no more credible
today than when they first brought it to
this Council six months ago
so while I believe this meeting is the
Colossal waste of time and we should
decide just how much of our time we
allow Russia to waste I'm glad this
Council has the chance to see Russia's
disinformation campaign for what it is
an attempt to distract from the
atrocities Russian forces are carrying
out in Ukraine and a desperate tactic to
justify an unjustifiable War
ehouse
Ukraine has never ever developed
produced or stored a loner together with
someone else biological or chemical
weapons
our country does not possess a
corresponding infrastructure for
biological weapons development and
production
formally this provocative issue has been
already raised by Russia many times